[Music]  we were trying to make me believe in  reincarnation more yet because you're  pretty but you ain't her she got killed  still no arrests how come I wonder cuz  there ain't no God in the whole world is  empty and they don't matter what we do  to each other I hope not I don't know  what the police are doing  I hadn't heard a word from them and said  goddamn - I'll tell you this I've heard  an awful lot for them since I put them  billboards  [Music]  we keep casing Papa guy  better your chance at getting it solved  and take me down arrest me I've got  nothing to rescue for yeah you ain't if  I had some food I'd give it to you  well I got us some Doritos they might  kill you they're kind of pointy then  where would we be  [Music]